- C'est vraiment une partie
seulement de mon dossier
médical.
- Après des mois de délais
engendrés par la pandémie,
Nancy Marsolais a entamé
le 5 novembre son premier
traitement d'insémination
intra-utérine pour tomber
enceinte.
NANCY MARSOLAIS
- C'est un rêve qui est presque
viscéral, en fait, si on peut
dire ça comme ça.
- Au Québec, la Régie de
l'assurance maladie rembourse
cette procédure dont le taux
de réussite varie entre
3 et 25 % notamment selon
l'âge de la p
Dr ROLAND ANTAKI, obstétricien-
gynéco. Service reproduct. CHUM
- Lorsqu'un médecin voit
la patiente, habituellement,
on preaire
trois cycles d'insémination,
OK, donc trois traitements
ou trois cycles d'insémination
avant de revoir le médecin
pour changer le hanger le hange,
faire des modifications et tout.
Mais un cycle est vraiment...
c'est l'équivalent d'un seul
traitement.
- 22 novembre : le premier essai
a échoué. Nancy Marsolais
contacte sa clinique de
fertilité pour en effectuer
un deuxième. Mais les règles
ont changé avec l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi 73
sur la procréation assistée.
Depuis le 15 novembre, seules
les femmes de 41 ans moins
un jour sont admissibles
à un remboursement.
Nancy Marsolais
et 9 mois.
- J'ai fondu en larmes
au téléphone.
- Elle estime qu'un essai
lui coûteraitre
2100 et 2700 $. Elle juge que
les femmes de  41 ans et plus
qui ont entamé leur traitement
avant le 15 novembre doivent
pouvoir compléter trois cycles
gratuitement comme c'était
le cas avant l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi.
Par courriel, le cabinet
du ministre de la Santé
et des Services sociaux,
Lionel Carmant, répond :
- Je trouve ça un peu
épouvantable qu'on rajoute
ce stress-là aux femmes qui sont
déjà dans un processus
qui est hyper stressant.- Nancys
espoir, même si ce changement à
la loi l'amène à revoir la façon
lle réalislle réalislle réalisle
de devenir mère.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
-Canada, M